Brother, would you like your future wife
to wear a hijab? Brother, would I like
my future wife to wear THE HIJAB?
BROTHER, ALLAH HAS ALREADY COMMANDED MY
FUTURE WIFE TO WEAR THE HIJAB. ALLAH
WANTS MY FUTURE WIFE TO WEAR THE HIJAB.
SO, WHO AM I? HOW does this make him a
hypocrite? I'm trying to understand. If
he said Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has
already commanded it, meaning he has no
say in it. People who are coming out
here and backbiting and slandering, why?
Cuz they want to stain the dawa so they
can stop us from taking them to account.
And we're going to tell them over our
dead bodies. We're going to carry on
enjoying good and forbidding evil. I
don't care if you rip your hair out,
man.
IslamNet is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway,
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqa jariya
for you because every person that comes
a step [music] closer to Allah through
your donation, you will inshallah be
reaping the reward. Click the link and
donate what you can.
>> As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. So, this is a video I've been
double-minded about doing or not doing,
inshallah. Uh because allegations and
uh again, a smear campaign, and once
again, another brother's wife being
insulted, exposed, um himself being
deemed a hypocrite or whatever it is for
that matter. Now, I want to make
something very clear. And I've said this
before, and I'll say it again, brothers
and sisters. I do not have any kind of
loyalty to anybody.
I don't care who you are. I don't care
how close you to you are to me, okay?
When I came to Islam, I had to turn my
back against my father in a respectful
way because he deemed Islam to be wrong,
and he said the thing I hate the most is
being born into my family.
That's my father. That's my blood, yes?
But with us, they say blood is thicker
than water, which that means my
uh father and my family members' blood
are closer. But in Islam, we believe
iman is thicker than blood. So, my
loyalty is to Allah, his messenger, and
to the believers. Okay, which means
what? Subhanallah, that if we see the
Prophet Sallallahu Alayhi "Aid your
brother if he's oppressed or the
oppressor." They said, "O messenger of
Allah, we know how to aid our brother
who is oppressed, but how do we aid the
oppressor?" He said, "By speaking out
against his oppression." And this is
what it is about today, brothers and
sisters, because I believe unjustly,
alhamdulillah, and this is going to be
evidence from the Quran and Sunnah. It's
not Ali's words. Ali's words mean zero.
Take it and throw it in the bin or put
it in the recycle bin. It means nothing.
We're going to go to this Quran and the
Sunnah what Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
says, what the scholars says, what
Abdullah ibn Abbas said. Alhamdulillah,
this is what we work with. I'm not kez.
Yes, I'm not someone who just comes and
makes stuff up, etc., my whims and
desires. Uh this guy I exposed AK, who
is a munafiq, who is a kafir, five-star
grade A kafir who was pretending to be a
Muslim. And jahils, ignoramuses, are
coming out and saying, "You can't do
takfir of him." Someone saying they
reject the Quran, they don't takfir of
him. Anyways, alhamdulillah, they just
exposed the ignorance. So,
what we're going to do is this, brothers
and sisters. There is allegations or
stuff that's been coming out about
brother Tally and his wife. He got newly
married. May Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
preserve and bless his marriage and
protect them from all harm. What is the
allegation? He used to talk about hijab,
and now he's married to a woman who
doesn't wear the hijab.
>> Guys be like, "GO WEAR A HIJAB."
BROTHER,
WHO GAVE YOU PERMISSION TO LOOK? LOWER
YOUR GAZE. You wouldn't talk to your
mother like that. Shh.
I'm up for you, little boy. Okay. Number
one, let's understand something. If an
individual, islamically, islamically,
the one that does a sin
privately, somebody goes and exposes
that, it is a heinous major crime.
Meaning, in the sharia, if somebody goes
and spies in someone's house, and in
that house, they are doing
homosexuality,
they are doing some crazy stuff, they
will be punished. Why? That is someone's
privacy and what goes in there. Now,
if if,
argument's sake, I portray myself to be
a certain way on the camera, and behind
cameras, I'm a zalim, I'm an oppressor,
and I go and do audhubillah all kinds of
mad stuff, etc., Allah will expose me.
Okay?
But, the point is here, brothers and
sisters. Tally, what would you do? In
the videos that he would do, brothers
and sisters, he would say that Allah has
commanded the woman to wear the hijab.
Is this haq? Of course it's haq. He has
said that hijab is important. It's
important for him to remind her. No
problem. Now, the point is the
following, which I find it um very
bizarre, okay? Very bizarre. That the
accusation is what? Because he said that
Allah has commanded, cuz when he says,
for example, which you you see the video
inshallah in a minute, is "Oh, would you
want your wife to wear a hijab?" He
said, "It's not what I would want, it's
what Allah has commanded." How does this
make him a hypocrite? I'm trying to
understand. If he said Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala has already commanded it, meaning
he has no say in it. Do you prefer your
future wife to wear the hijab?
Um I think it's completely up to her.
Mhm. That looks like the Illuminati
triangle.
Brother, would you like your future wife
to wear a hijab?
Brother, would I like my future wife to
wear THE HIJAB? BROTHER, ALLAH HAS
ALREADY COMMANDED MY FUTURE WIFE TO WEAR
THE HIJAB. ALLAH WANTS MY FUTURE WIFE TO
WEAR THE HIJAB. SO, WHO AM I TO SAY
whether or not she should wear the hijab
or not?
BETTER THAN HIJAB, DO NIQAB.
>> [laughter]
>> ANYTHING ELSE?
Anything else, brother?
Are you satisfied?
Yes, brother.
Okay.
Smile.
It's sunnah. If, for Of course, he has a
choice to say I wouldn't want to marry a
hijabee or not. But, for example, if
somebody has seen a good character in a
sister who doesn't wear the hijab,
who prays their salah, to me, I believe
this is and I've shared my experience
before, and I say it without any shame.
When I was looking to get married long
time ago, at one moment of time, I just
had bad experiences getting to know
sisters in a halal way who observed the
hijab, who had niqab, who had jilbab on.
And there, the experience was so
terrifying and so bad, I actually at one
moment said I prefer to marry a sister
who doesn't observe the hijab, but prays
salah. Why? Cuz my ghira to Allah's haq
is greater than my ghira for myself of
her hair being shown, which is also a
sin, but salah is a major of a major sin
that takes you out of the fold of Islam.
So, I embarked on that journey, and I
can remember meeting one or two sisters
who wouldn't observe the hijab, who were
praying their salah. It just didn't work
out. Alhamdulillah, I ended up marrying
a woman who alhamdulillah observes the
hijab. Now, why am I mentioning this?
Brothers and sisters,
the point is the following. If Tally was
to say,
"Brothers, fear Allah.
Do you You're a dayuth. If you don't
marry a woman who doesn't observe the
hijab, you're a dayuth. You are like
this. You are like that. You should make
sure that you marry one with hijab."
then I would say 100% what you said is
true. This is hypocrisy. You went out
and portrayed and pursued pushed
something out, and then when it came to
you, brother, everything changed. Did he
say that? No, he didn't from what I
know. He didn't.
>> who doesn't care what his woman wears
doesn't care about his woman. He's a
dayuth. He's like a handbag who gets
carried around on a woman's arm. He's
only useful for picking up the
groceries, or he's a tool that's used in
the bed at night. A real man who loves
his woman cares about what his woman
wears. He wants people to respect her
and protects her from the men who don't
care what their women wear. So, does
this mean now, let's go back to the
Quran and the Sunnah. Like I said, not
my words, not Tally's words. Like I said
before,
my loyalty is to Allah and his
messenger. Let's talk about what Allah
and his messenger says. Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala in the Quran says what? Okay,
chapter 3, verse 104. So, what does
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala say in the
Quran? Allah says in the Quran,
"And let there Let there be amongst you
a group of people who invite to good and
command the evils. Those indeed are the
successful ones." Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala is saying this, yeah? Allah is
not saying, "Let there rise amongst you
a group of sinless people."
Yes? And in this matter, can we say that
brother Tally is committing a sin? No,
because as a man who is married, okay,
his job is to remind his woman folk or
his
um
men folk in his house if they're
committing whatever it is for that
matter, his job is to remind. Now, what
this has come to is because we know the
whole attack against the dawa bros
that's been termed a coin that's been uh
termed uh termed that's been coined by
the LGBTQ kufar to attack the dawa.
Alhamdulillah, and every single one of
them have been exposed one by one.
Alhamdulillah. One's a munafiq, uh one's
talking a absolute ignorance, talking
with no evidence from the Quran and
Sunnah. One's LGBTQ, one is a
supporting a trans. Alhamdulillah, Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala has exposed them.
Now, the thing is, they're making it
seem as if there's hypocrisy. I'm so
sorry, with all due respect. Number one,
you cannot call him a dayuth. Yes? Those
pictures that were taken, yes? They are
private, okay? And for someone to go and
expose that, which from what I know,
from what I've been told, has been
exposed by a kafir, a woman who's not
even a Muslim, for whatever reason, yes?
Okay. Number one, these are leaked
things. It's not something where he went
and put out, which you can come and say
he's a dayuth for that matter, whatever
it is, yeah? Okay, even the word dayuth,
like Abdullah
Sheikh bin Baz says, it is a man who has
no care about his woman folk sleeping
around. So, you guys use the words, do
it. And it's all the rewards that are
going on to Yawm al-Qiyamah. Tally and
his wife, they're going to enjoy it.
Alhamdulillah. Let me be honest with
you.
You don't do hijab properly, take it
off. Don't ever say that. A man who
drinks alcohol, his prayer won't be
accepted for 40 days, but he still needs
to pray. The same way a woman needs to
practice hijab, whether she does it
properly or not. But if you become the
reason to stop the man from praying
because he drinks alcohol, or you become
the reason the woman takes off her
hijab, then you are also responsible for
them sinning.
Be warned. Astaghfirullah.
This smear campaign that's come between
to towards me and my wife.
Alhamdulillah, look, I'll be honest with
you. How can I complain complain? Like
Umar ibn Khattab said, "If I knew who it
is, I would give them gifts." On Yawm
al-Qiyamah, the the the accusations,
these stuff. I mean, I've even heard
documentaries coming about me. I cannot
wait. Let it rain in. Alhamdulillah. We
all need it. What does the Sunnah say?
Now, let's go to this, inshallah. And
Hudhayfah ibn al-Yaman said what? Uh the
He said Hudhayfah ibn al-Yaman quoted
the the Sallallahu Alayhi Wasallam
saying, "By the one who's hand my soul,
you must certainly command the good and
forbid the evil, or else a punishment
from him would soon be sent upon you,
after which you would be called to him
to supplicate, and it would not be
answered." This is in Tirmidhi, okay?
Another narration states that punishment
from abandoning the obligation is
sweeping and in general afflicting both
the righteous and the corrupt. Abdullah
ibn Adam commented that punishment can
be manifest as the tyrant of leaders,
the dominion of the enemies, and other
forms of tribulations. The Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said, "I
swear by Allah when conveying this." And
he said that supplication itself is
unanswered until the community returns
to enjoying the good and forbidding the
evil. And then we've got absolute
ignoramuses which I'm going to go see
soon in Bradford, inshallah. He was
saying, "Yeah, you know what you tell
your brothers to do with no single
evidence from the Quran or Sunnah, not
one evidence." And he even told me why
he's not
speaking against it. I cannot tell you,
it's an amanah that he mentioned to me
on the phone when he called me. He's
like a
soft-spoken, the arrogance went and
anyways. So, the Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said, he described um he
described that when the people of
knowledge in previous communities
stopped condemning the evil of their
societies and kept on socializing with
evil doers despite the wrongs, Allah
turned the hearts of the community
against one another and cursed upon the
tongue of their prophets. Cursed upon
the tongue of their prophets, yes?
And to get annoyed, listen to this very
carefully, subhanallah. This is where it
just shows you, subhanallah, how the
haqq prevails. And to get annoyed when
corrected, it's self a major sin.
Abdullah ibn Masud, may Allah have mercy
on him, said, "Verily, among the
greatest of sins in the sight of Allah
is for a person to be told, 'Fear
Allah,' to which he responds, 'Mind your
business.'"
Yes?
Subhanallah. So, brothers and sisters,
if somebody, like I said before,
whatever it is, I'm in the dawah,
whatever it is, imagine my daughter
doesn't wear the hijab.
So, you're telling me I need to stop
doing dawah cuz my daughter doesn't wear
the hijab. Imagine I have a son who is a
drunkard.
Yes? And I advise against drinking
alcohol,
but I also advise him not to drink
alcohol, but he doesn't listen to me.
Yes? And he still does it. Okay? So,
what are you going to say? I have to
stop dawah, bring you evidence from the
Quran and Sunnah that says to me that I
have to stop my dawah because a family
member of mine is committing a sin.
Qul hatu burhanakum in kuntum sadiqeen.
Bring your evidences if you're truthful.
Otherwise, you're talking out of whims
and desires. Bring evidences, brother.
I'm not here for your opinion, bro. I
don't care who you are. I don't care if
you came out some kind of a trauma, yes?
Okay, with your ex-husband or your
ex-wife, I don't care.
I am talking about, brother, bring me
evidence. I don't care if you used to be
someone who was a red-pill
red-pill oppressor who used to oppress
his wives, yes? Who caused one of his
wives to leave Islam and now you're
traumatized and you became a simp. I
don't care, bro. That's your
experiences. Keep yourself off the
internet, bro. We don't want to witness
your trauma. So, so to come here and
then say, "Oh, he's a hypocrite, these
dawah bros." It is just a cop-out for
what? To not take accountability.
And if you think, I told brother Talib,
yes?
Carry on your dawah, bro. Don't let them
stop you. Carry on your dawah because
you've said clearly and categorically
that you advise your wife,
alhamdulillah. And like I said before,
that is the choice that you've made,
bro, we all have a struggle
uh struggles.
All of us do. But one thing that you
need to understand is Talib doesn't come
here and say, "Oh, like, you know, cool
cool to the evil or do this." No. He's
somebody who talks against the evil.
He's someone who does reminders. Guys
need to understand that hijabis in
today's society face a lot of criticism,
which makes it extremely difficult for
them to practice. So, we need to be kind
and supportive towards them. And to the
women, keep going, keep trying, you're
getting there. The only thing that
matters is your relationship with Allah.
And the same thing like with sister
Khadijah, after Khadijah, she took her
hijab off, everyone turned against her.
Sisters turned against her, slandering
her that she leaked her pictures on
purpose. Fear Allah.
A man or a woman, which means what?
Look, she done so much good for the
community. How could you write her off
and say, "Don't do no more dawah." I'll
even tell her, "You took your hijab off,
still advise women to wear the hijab."
Yes? It's not hypocrisy. You know why?
It's a struggle. You can come and say,
"Look, I I'm struggling with my hijab."
But for those sisters out there who are
who are
who don't know how to wear hijab, this
is how you put your hijab on. Wallahi,
in the sight of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala,
that's a righteousness. And Allah says,
"Repel uh the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam says, the rip um
do a good deed, if you've done a sin, do
a good deed, for it will, inshallah,
counter counteract it or something along
those lines, okay? So, this is our deen.
So, bring me evidence from the Quran and
Sunnah that he should stop the dawah or
dawah or he's a hypocrite. Assalamu
Alaykum, everyone. I recently saw a
video of a girl, I'm not going to
mention her name, who wears fake nails
throughout the year, but decided to take
them off for Ramadan. So many people
criticized her saying that the fake
nails stop the water from touching the
actual nails during wudu, which is
necessary for prayer. And she admits
that she doesn't pray throughout the
year, but at least she's trying for
Ramadan. Now, think about this. Ramadan
is known as the month of forgiveness and
transformation. It's a time when we
change our habits and strengthen our
relationship with Allah. If there is
ever a time to give it your all into
practicing Islam, it's the month of
Ramadan because it has the power to
change lives. If there is somebody who
is trying to change in the month of
Ramadan for the sake of Allah, who are
you to judge them? My message to
everybody and that sister is to embrace
the change, make Ramadan that catalyst
that will take you closer to Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. It doesn't matter how
religious you are, we all need that
self-improvement in Ramadan. So, take
the step and smile, it's Sunnah.
Evidences, bro, please. Yes? Don't move
like this Kes guy, an absolute ignoramus
who called me. I asked him evidence from
the Quran and Sunnah. He told me the
reason why he doesn't enjoy good and
forbid evil towards a specific gender
is because of someone in his family
member, which I can't go into detail.
You can't make this up. Alhamdulillah,
not a single evidence was brought. The
point I'm saying is this, guys. And he's
the same guy
who talked about
talked about Talib and his wife.
Calling them out with not a single
evidence.
That's the reason why we are going to
meet him. That's why I'm going to,
inshallah, find him and talk to him,
inshallah, and expose his reality, which
I did on the phone. And I didn't record
it because it's haram for me uh to
record it. Yes, inshallah. And by the
way, when someone comes and says, "Well,
hold on a second though, that AK guy, he
was also secretly recorded." No, he was
pretending to be a munafiq, somebody
who's pretending to be a Muslim doing
Islamic reminders, quoting the Quran
while he rejected it. That's not the
same because this community and the
people who done that, may Allah bless
them, they're not snakes. May Allah
bless them for exposing his hypocrisy,
trying to doubt put doubts in the
people's mind about hadith while he is a
kafir. He doesn't believe in Islam. So,
it is not the same thing. I thought I'd
touch on that before somebody clips it
out, inshallah. Brothers and sisters,
may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala protect
brother Talib and his wife and everyone
out there, subhanallah, whoever they
are, subhanallah,
uh from people who are coming out here
and backbiting and slandering. Why? Cuz
they want to stain the dawah so they can
stop us from taking them to account. And
we're going to tell them over our dead
bodies. We're going to carry on enjoying
good and forbidding evil. I don't care
if you rip your hair out, man. Color
your hair green, blue, yellow, rainbow
color. We're not going to stop because
we can see you guys are aligned to that.
You have the LGBTQ thing, okay? Yeah,
you say you love them, no problem.
Listen, we're never going to stop. So,
if you think this is going to stop us or
you're going to bring a documentary and
we're going to be like, "Oh, no, we
can't do dawah anymore." Wallahi, let me
tell you something. We are never going
to stop and we will call to to the haqq,
inshallah, and to defend this deen
against its enemies, be they Muslims,
munafiqs, kuffar, trans, LGBTQ, even if
you're an alien. Till next time.
Assalamu Alaykum Wa Rahmatullahi Wa
Barakatuh.